and ego is a real thing that blinds us
man you know you don't think anybody
else could do it as good as you that's
not true they can uh and you also don't
want to let go of things and I also
thought that on think media people were
going to be like dude he's sold out man
I can't believe that Sean handed the
editing off and I remember I went on
meetup.com here in Las Vegas I started
to go to creative meetups like blogging
meetups podcasting meetups one was
actually called Las Vegas creatives
meetups and I met a guy named Jay and
again local community and he and he
started to edit for us I remember when
he did it first and US was my wife and I
so we're just starting you know and uh
one of the first times he finished a
video when I uploaded I go this is it
this is the fall of think media I was
like I was like tomorrow the comments
they're gonna say Sean how could you you
stopped editing we can tell you sold out
how dare you and this is the end that's
literally what's going through my head
and then I uploaded the video and guess
how many comments I got about there
being different editing
zero